You started an online store, and
the customers are rolling in.
Your website is functional art,
your ad campaign's gone viral,
and the shopping
carts are filling up.
Your products have
universal appeal.
And you notice, Hey!
I'm huge in Japan.
You are getting lots of
international traffic.
But it's not
converging into sales.
Why is that?
After examining
your analytics data,
you see a lot of items getting
abandoned during checkout.
Do your international users just
have a shorter attention span?
Or is there
something sub-optimal
about the user experience
that is frustrating
their urge to consume?
We're going to address
these questions
and elucidate some of
the famous question marks
that beget profit.
Have you ever seen
an address in Japan?
Let's start with something
easy for me as an American.
Here's where I work
in Los Angeles.
But here's where
Googlers work in Japan.
Let's remove the language
barrier for a second.
As you might notice, we're
not in Kansas anymore.
The order of this address is
almost completely reversed
from Western conventions.
But you're smart.
You can handle this.
You whip out some JavaScript
and manipulate that DOM.
After a careful
reading of Wikipedia,
you are pretty confident.
You can deal with users
coming from Japan,
shuffle the others
around to make
sure they feel right at home,
remove any impediments that
might prevent them
from obtaining
the latest in wearable
tech for their pets.
But wait a second.
Every country does things
a little differently.
How many countries are
there in the world?
I don't know-- a bunch.
You're going to be up
pretty late tonight
scouring the web for
this sort of information
for every country
that likes cats.
That's problem one.
Now, here's problem two.
Here is that address again.
But this time it
contains a typo.
Can you spot it?
I can't either.
But users love typos--
almost more than their cats.
So you better figure out
how to verify the address
as it's being entered.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
OK I will end this rant.
I hope you are convinced.
Addresses are hard.
And you just want
to go shopping.
But it's OK.
Chrome's requestAutocomplete
gives you all this
and more for free.
RequestAutocomplete is a
brand-spanking new member
of the HTML standard.
And today, you can
find it on Chrome
for desktop, Chrome
OS, Android, and iOS.
And it's super easy to integrate
into your site, which is nice.
RequestAutocomplete
remembers the address.
So in practice,
most of the time,
you won't need to
enter a new one.
But when you do, here is what
it looks like on your phone.
It's native UI.
So this is straightforward
to use as an American.
You can put in your name,
my city, all that stuff.
That's well and good.
But here's the
hard part-- Russia.
As you might have expected
the address fields
look quite different
from the United States.
For example, you see the
postal code and the city fields
on top of the street
address and the name fields.
What about validation, you ask?
No problem.
RequestAutocomplete
can do that as well.
Fantastic.
Best of all, next
time my address
is ready and waiting for me.
So Chrome handles address input,
data validation, and more,
while you focus on your product.
Want to add requestAutocomplete
to your site?
Check it out here or
point your browser here.
Easier internationalization
is just one reason
why requestAutocomplete rocks.
The team is working hard to
improve the checkout process
for your users.
Our goal is to help you maximize
conversions and optimize
the payments experience for the
web, especially the mobile web.
Because let's face it.
This resource is occupied.
Until next time, I'm
Rouslan Solomakhin.
And I'm huge in Japan.
[GRUNTING]